bursting with life Leah died because of
one bad decision but also from what's
been described today as a national
problem hidden in plain sight
the first Leah's mum realized it was
when Medics were trying to resuscitate
her daughter I knew as soon as I got
back there was police there was other
nurses around that I knew just by their
reaction it wasn't good they had their
heads down
Leah had overdosed on MDMA whilst out
with friends she lived here in
northallerton Rishi sunas constituency
which doesn't look like it has a youth
drug problem but does and it's often
children who are selling the drugs
Tammy's teenage son supplied the MDMA
that killed Leah she doesn't want us to
give his name but he got sucked into
county lines dealing from the age of 14.
and Tammy says for three years she
couldn't get support to get him out
three days before Leah died the police
were in my house I was asking for help
and if there is something would have
happened those three days or when he was
14 he should not have gone to jail and
Leo would be here this is exactly the
problem identified by today's report
from the commission on young lives one
of the things we get we got told time
and time again was that you know when a
parent found the horrific burner phone
in a child's bedroom or a knife or some
cash they'd ring up Social Services or
they'd ring up the police but no one
could help them
Leah's mom thinks people who deal to
teenagers should get tougher sentences
but recognizes the boy who supplied
Leah's drugs was himself exploited he
was groomed he was groomed and to do
this
um I don't think he's a horrible person
do you think he's a victim yeah
100 percent
a report by the commission on young
lives today recommended a sure start for
teenagers bringing support and
intervention together in local hubs
backed up by what it calls an army of
Youth workers and schools remaining open
during school holidays and weekends as
safe places for children along with an
additional 1 billion pounds investment
to combat teenage mental health problems
with money raised from social media
companies
it used to be the case you'd have 11 12
13 year olds who were running delivering
the drugs now that's going down 9 10 11
but also where you've got young
teenagers 13 14 actually heading up
county lines delivering drugs across the
country you know running a business here
in a very ruthless way
previously we've met gangs running
county lines looking to exploit children
this is what I give to the people and
the little kids they all go out for me
and the report says with the cost of
living crisis more children are easy
prey research by the YMCA published
earlier this year found across the
country the annual spend on Child
Services has fallen by 74 percent in the
last decade and what this report is
calling for is more investment
there in the inner cities or the
Yorkshire Countryside reversing those
Trends won't be easy it's not just about
let's throw this money here it's about
how we're going to do it who's going to
be trained on it
you know and where are they going to get
the social workers and the youth workers
because nobody wants to come into Health
and Social Care at the minute
the report argues that investing in
preventing children from being exploited
in the long term would save huge costs
within the criminal justice system as
well as preventing heartache for
families Jason Farrell Sky News